was ist ihr lösungsvorschlag
gelegen also ich finde das ja schon mal
erst mal gut dass wir so mein herz
schlägt das erst mal viele politiker die
führende ämter annehmen erstens schon
mal aus diesem bereich kommen das wäre
sehr hilfreich und zweitens vielleicht
auch in ihr leben schon mal gearbeitet
haben und nicht direkt vom studium in
die politik fallen weil dann ist man ein
bisschen weltfremd und wenn mir ein
kanzler erzählt der heute kanzler ist
dass er nicht mal weiß was sein wenn was
sprit kostet ja dann ist er so weit weg
von jeglicher realität dass es einfach
weh tut und ich bin sehr bürgernah
kommen von ganz unten und ich werde dich
nie vergessen wo ich herkomme aber ein
politiker nicht alle es gibt nicht die
politik es gibt aber einige die sind
wirklich für weltfremd haben ja gar
nicht diesen diese kopplung zu den
normalen bürgern und dann würde ich da
haben sie richtig schön gesagt ein
bisschen demut mir wünschen ein bisschen
bürgernähe dass sie sich mal hinstellen
und einfach sich informieren was kostet
ein laib brot jetzt damit zu verstehen
[Musik]